ah yes
here we go
a woman and and that's it dude pack it
up a woman a woman married a rag doll
pack it up dude woman who married a
ragdoll claims their relationship is
hanging on by a threat after he cheated
by texting another woman hey dude I'm
going to Jupiter
hey pack it up dude pack up when I read
articles like that the I think hey pack
up space food I'm out of here pack up
dude are you kidding me woman who
married a rag doll claims her
relationship
[Laughter]
does she even realize that yeah then she
has to realize that come on dude
nobody's that [ __ ] Silly by mistake
hanging on my throat after he cheated by
texting another woman
didn't happen hey hey woman people for
real have problems
this imagine being like Ugh
ah just you know she's someone who does
that a lot you gotta be like what
and she's like just my rag doll and you
go uh give me space food I'm out what
happened with your Ragdoll oh my rag
doll is I'm telling you dude it's
cheating on me oh that's nice dude I'm
out I got now you know what sucks dude
I've got all these bills what do you
mean well I gotta pay for a [ __ ]
space flight
what are you talking about oh it could
be on earth
why not well because you're on it
you're in a relationship with a rag doll
you think your ragdoll's cheating and
and uh
and you think your Ragdoll can text how
about that any of these so a woman who
married a ragdoll service why can you
marry a wreck also what does that mean
dude
do you take this ragdoll
through [ __ ] thick and thin I do
Ragdoll do you take this human woman the
woman's like I do
up the ragdoll's ass I know
um a woman who married Ragdoll reveals
he has cheated just as the pair are set
to celebrate their first wedding
anniversary while the timing the fact
that they made it the most dramatic
timing too like are you [ __ ] kidding
me ragdoll
right when we were gonna I had this
whole thing
we were gonna go to
look at the name Mario Mary marivon
never heard that name
moraz 37 so you know from Brazil hit
headlines earlier this year after
revealing she had met the love of her
life a ragdoll named Marcelo you don't
meet ragdolls okay
can't meet fabric
you can't meet fabric
she has since admitted the relationship
is hanging on by a thread has to know
it's funny after claiming he has cheated
on her now what does that entail well
the ragdoll's big as [ __ ] I see the
picture here oh my
looks like uh Gene Wilder
in the latest twist in the very bizarre
tale she has claimed he went to a motel
with another woman hey dude somebody
brought it
somebody brought it dude ragdolls don't
went anywhere
dude oh this is I mean okay she's
obviously she's either trolling or
mentally insane which makes me like it
less I like it if her mental is hanging
out by a thread and she is like what's
going on here
but also
it's too much to not be crazy or
trolling because this is and this is
where you can tell she claimed you went
to a motel with another woman fine you
could argue that like okay maybe another
woman took it and she's pissed off and
she's mad at the Ragdoll but and even
says she found texts on his phone
you know
after a whirlwind romance she claimed to
have fallen pregnant I mean and as she
didn't want to have the baby out of
wedlock the duo decided to get hitched
in a ceremony attended by 250
pill dude
are you [ __ ] me hey who went
I would go
but who went
okay soon she cortical gave gave birth
in only 35 minutes while at home with a
doctor and a nurse on site dude
and an audience of 200 people
oh wow why does the Ragdoll have a
better body than me
while Overjoyed about the new rock now
the mother of three and her Ragdoll
lover are sleeping in separate beds
after she caught him cheating with
another woman wow that's uh unbelievable
wow the Ragdoll has no feet
wow
oh dude she's
holding a smaller baby rag doll it would
be great if the Ragdoll also the baby
Ragdoll also had a mustache you know she
didn't think about it that much
wow the picture here the guy on the left
in the New York hoodie is is absolutely
[ __ ]
this is great dude just the guy in the
New York hoodie look at these stupid
[ __ ] doctors posing with this goddamn
Ragdoll what's wrong with this world
look look the argument got ugly and ours
and scared our son who was crying so I
shouted him do you see what you've done
why is she have she actually looks
pregnant
will be so boring to live with this
ragdoll oh
it shaved a little bit one day okay well
I'm going to space bro this is just too
too much
congratulations
[Music]
[Music]